[Musique]
bienvenue dans envies de lecture de la
nive holtz bonjour bonjour on trouve à
se projeter
on s'entend en 2121 avec notre invité
thierry schwab
bonjour bonjour alors on a eu des petits
problèmes de liaison c'est pour ça qu'on
vous voit avec un téléphone mais voilà
on l'habitude d'être au téléphone et
peut-être qu'on le sera encore plus
demain je ne sais pas nous publions donc
optima 2121 le monde dans son temps si
proche si différent c'est le sous-titré
7 aux éditions l'ombre rouge
un mot sur vous je crois que votre votre
père était notamment l'auteur de grandes
chansons pour pour les artistes de
l'avant époque yéyé s'il se peut dire
vous même vous êtes polytechnicien vous
avez été un des pionniers français de
l'internet et en même temps vous avez
toujours une fibre artistique que vous
développez avec une galerie qui porte
votre nom qui doit dans le 3e
arrondissement paris et puis avec cette
maison d'édition l'ombre rouge et votre
monde remonte dans le dernier optima
2021 dont nous allons parler
nathalie alors l'histoire c'est celle
d'un journaliste scientifique qui va
être propulsé par un astrophysicien dans
l'avenir lors pas n'importe quel avenir
donc 100 ans c'est à dire en 2121 et il
est envoyé comme ça dans le monde futur
qui s'appelle optima est envoyé là bas
pour six mois
un peu comme un astronaute mais un
astronaute de l'avenir et le soutien de
votre livre c'est un monde si proche et
si différents oui c'est ça on a
l'impression que l'avenir est d'élever
la raf qui va se passer dans ce sens
tant tout est déjà en germe
aujourd'hui il me semble d'abord si
proche effectivement parce que les la
plupart je pense avoir tout cas beaucoup
d enfants qui naissent aujourd'hui soit
encore vivant dans 30 ans vont connaître
le monde et puis l'autre partie les jeux
je voulais avec les chirac beaucoup des
problèmes qui se posent aujourd'hui et
dont je décris un peu les prolongements
qu'on peut attendre en 2121
on a tous beaucoup d'inquiétude sur
l'avenir de la planète et de l'humanité
par rapport au réchauffement climatique
par rapport aux problèmes des
démocraties face aux dictatures est
inquiétante
la perte de la diverses d'adieu
diversité de l'irruption dans tous les
domaines de l'intelligence artificielle
et donc ça m'a intéressé et amusé
d'essayer de décrire ce monde mais d'une
façon romanesque avec une trame le fils
qui en parlent beaucoup d'amour aussi
dans ce livre est au niveau de
technologie mais c'est vrai que c'est
dur est passé dans la on va où va
feuilleter un peu ce qui pourrait
étonner les lecteurs premier étonnement
par exemple c'est que on peut faire
l'amour avec une femme qui a 100 ans et
vous m'ont dit les fait pas et oui qui
apparaît 40-45 pas ce que je fais pas si
vous savez mais en 2052 on a découvert
l'immortalité
voilà et est ce qu a posé un peu plus
tard la question des enfants mais mais
ça veut dire qu'on a su faire en sorte
que nos cellules qui meurt en permanence
soit soient remplacées par d'autres et
qu'on se stabilise à l'âge de 45 50 ans
donc effectivement cette femme à l'air
d'être une quadragénaire en forme et en
fait c'est une centenaire qui choque un
petit peu le héros c'est vrai que vous
vous montrez au fond que vous parlez de
cette date de 2000 e 50 d'où votre
ecofolio référendum qui a été organisée
à 2099 où on pose la question suivante
est ce que vous préférez l'immortalité
ou bien la limitation du nombre
d'enfants par femme et il n'y a pas eu
photo 1 pour l'immortalité et que notre
choix c'était de décider de soi même de
mourir à 100 ou 120 ans pour laisser la
place aux autres mais je pourquoi que
vous le feriez moi non plus quoi
et donc effectivement finalement la
population a fait ce choix là donc en
2121 ya presque plus d'enfants il y a eu
quelques naissances clandestine alors ça
a beaucoup de conséquences allaient les
écoles ferment progressivement puisqu'il
ya plus d'élèves etc
mais voilà c'est un des aspects
effectivement majeur qui peut se poser
parce que je
c'est pas totalement n'importe quoi vous
savez qu'il ya en ce moment beaucoup de
recherches qui portent sur ce thème chez
google par exemple sur peut-être pas
forcément l'immortalité mais une ligue
beaucoup plus longue
rien d des spécialistes de ce qu'on
appelle l'homme augmenté d'intelligence
artificielle qui disent aujourd'hui
disent que bon enfant qui va vivre trois
cents ans et est à peu près probablement
né aujourd'hui quoi et ça tout à fait on
entre dans ce monde c'est un fait alors
il y en a beaucoup d'autres mais celui
ci est un aspect majeur y en a un autre
majeur je préfère peut-être qu'ils font
c'est le fait le rapport au travail le
chômage y arrivait justement
oui le rapport au travail alors ça c'est
le deuxième étonnement dans dans ce
livre parce que dans ce monde de 202
dans sortant et bien on travaille plus
il ya des robots pour ça que plus voilà
est hélas encore dans un monde dominé
par l'intelligence artificielle et où il
existe des robots et bien on voit qu'il
est tout à fait plausible élevé ou
d'ailleurs est perturbé par ce que il
pense être enfin c'est un chômage voilà
qui est un chômage de demain c'est pas
tout à fait ça c'est très intéressant
ce que vous décrivez d'ailleurs sur cet
attachement au travail exactement parce
que pour nous aujourd'hui et plus être
aux chômeurs c'est plutôt une anomalie
même si dans nos sociétés dès chômeurs
sont en général correctement rémunérés
ils souffrent parce que le parce que la
norme c'est le travail mais dans un
monde mais quand on est en vacances on
ne trouve pas de pas travailler quand on
est à la retraite non plus aidé en vain
et dans un monde où effectivement il ya
presque plus personne qui travaille il
n'y a pas de souffrance qui attaquent à
condition qu ont effectivement trouvé
des moyens intéressants de s'occuper
dont dont la communication avec autrui
qui est quelque chose d'important
l'amitié l'amour et puis toutes sortes
d'autres activités donc c'est vrai qu'à
qu'à cette époque là alors ça c'est
quelque chose auquel je croise il ya pas
d économistes réfléchissent beaucoup à
ça à un horizon de 20 ou 30 ans il
semble pas que l'ia va détruire trop en
faire et si elle détruit beaucoup de
métier de tâches d'encre et beaucoup
d'autres mais un horizon de son temps on
peut penser que les intelligents
religieuses seront réalisés à peu près
tout ce que nous on réalise
et de façon plus rapide plus efficace
travaillant beaucoup plus que nous et
donc je crois effectivement que la
notion de travail les compétences changé
de sens et que dans ce cas ce moment là
on travaillera plus alors je serais pas
là pour le voir d'immortalité ça peut
être autre chose sur laquelle vous
insistez alors qu'il prolonge bout pour
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est la
gouvernance du monde au fond sur les
états unis la chine qui sont partagés on
parle on crée on pas yohann exactement
je crois que la vision et un peu créé
dirais que cette réunification du monde
interviendra peut-être pas dans son
temps mais plus tard si l'humanité
existe toujours mais il ya un mouvement
historique
enfin que tout le monde connaît on est
on est parti de deux familles d'une
tribu de sites et de prix
on est en train de constituer l'europe
etc donc il ya un mouvement vers
l'unification du monde qui est assez
naturel est qui et qui résulte du fait
d'abord de du rétrécissement des de la
terre vont entonner on circule à toute
vitesse et des informations
instantanément était ensuite du fait que
beaucoup de problèmes de plus en plus de
problèmes nécessite une approche globale
pour être résolus donc effectivement
c'est un mouvement qui va se produire
alors ensuite prévoir que c'est la chine
qui va dominer demande économiquement ça
c'est pas un scoop je crois c'est assez
probable que l'anglais va dominer ça me
paraît assez probable aussi pour des
raisons qui presque m voilà mais je sais
que je suis un peu soi puis mr
pessimiste parce que tout le monde après
une vision positive pour te voir que
dans son temps il y aura plus qu'un état
et qui porteront plus ce nom un petit
peu ironique de optima système politique
à ces démocraties s'est restreinte parce
que au fond on est les plus qu'aux gros
que les pouvoirs locaux
voilà ouais alors ça je crois que tu
l'aies on a un vrai problème aujourd'hui
un fail c'est le problème de démocratie
et du processus électoral avec de plus
en plus de gens qu'ils s'en détournent
l'énorme problème des chèques news ddd
un fox comme disent nos cousins
québécois et donc on a un vrai problème
avec ça et donc j'imagine un système où
on en est lui que pour les très pro
dirigeants qui sont les maires et c'est
eux qui vont successivement par strates
successives et lire jusqu'au président
du monde et ce faisant on échappe
notamment beaucoup c'est cuit ou ce
parce que tu as plus grand intérêt de
démettre des fausses informations justes
hurle sur un petit maire local bon on
peut on ne peut pas tout raconter mais
le héros qui est célibataire et qui n'a
pas d'enfant va partir comme ça dans le
futur et il va rencontrer ça c'est très
émouvant ses enfants ses petits-enfants
alors c'est vrai que les lecteurs se
posent la question de savoir si on peut
revenir sur ce futur écrit et c'est
s'amender ressort de votre roman
c'est vrai une question philosophique on
peut se poser à partir du moment
peut-être qu'effectivement un jour on a
on a une connaissance du futur là une
grande question qui se pose est ce qu'on
peut le modifier
voilà quel poids quel point le futur est
écrit bon c'est un petit peu paraître
peut-être mais c'est une question qui
peut se poser qui se poserait dans le
futur et et lui notamment voilà quand il
revient sur terre il va beaucoup hésité
à repartir assouvir une passion
amoureuse ou bien rester pour accomplir
le destin qu'il connaît mais parfois
compliquées savoir s'il aura le choix
d'ailleurs pas le choix on n'a pas de
tombe malheureusement parce que le temps
passe très vite mais c'est passionnant
elle sent que celui de parler du
conservatoire du malheur parce qu'ils
appelaient tous les jours car il n'y a
pas tellement de révolte un les gens
sont plutôt un sourire les visuels ou
alors il y en a quelques-uns qui sont en
prison mais dans ce dans ce
conservatoire du malheur on montre
comment été terrible la vie passe à bout
on les fait souffrir alors qu'il ya plus
de souffrance est terrible et il ya un
personnage qui est très important dans
le roman qui est dans ce conservatoire
mais là il faut le dire il faut lire le
livre je voulais quand même parce que
évidemment ya beaucoup de pistes de deux
choses qui existent aujourd'hui la
victoire contre la maladie
la procréation artificielle la
robotisation l'homme augmenté peut-être
la concentration des pouvoirs
dans les mains de quelques-uns si vous
étiez alors c'est un peu de travail de
futuro l'homme que vous avez fait est ce
que vous êtes un futurologue plutôt
optimiste plutôt pessimiste
j'ai peur de répondre plutôt pessimistes
voient alors par ailleurs ça fait une
remarque tu l'aies parmi les critiques
que j'ai ou les avis des lecteurs sur ce
livre c'est curieux de voir qu'il ya des
gens qui trouvent ce qu'ils trouvent
c'est une utopie amendes plutôt positif
et puis d'autres qu'on a vue inverse
donc c'est pas voilà parce qu'il ya des
choses très positives dans ce monde là
il ya quand même beaucoup de gens sont
pas très heureux de retravailler
il ya plus souffrance mais vide mais ça
monde on est hyper surveiller on côtoie
en permanence les ce que j'appelle les
robes des robots humanoïdes et puis
assez horrible conservateur du malheur
et il ya cette menace fer qui plane à
l'horizon d'une révolte de ces robots
humanoïdes extraordinaire tir alors mais
en fait moi j'ai plutôt une vision un
petit peu pessimiste mais je suis assez
inquiet sur sur ce que va sur l'ia
notamment peut-être plus et puis aussi
sur l'évolution politique du monde quoi
ça c'est comme des choses qui m'a
inquiété aussi le réchauffement
climatique l'étape un terme un peu plus
lointain mais je crois que l'image est
pas mal de gens pensent ça comme harari
si vous avez lu ses livres ou elon musk
ou d'autres que effectivement le lie à
risque et est à la fois une opportunité
mais un grand risque
la puissance des ordinateurs croît à une
vitesse qu'on ne peut pas imaginer
je vais vous citer un chiffre avec ebay
mais l'annoncé des comptes que sur une
petite un petit circuit imprimé qui sait
la taille d'un ongle
là où il ya 50 ans qui était déjà
extraordinaire on mettait 2000
transistors aujourd'hui on en met 20
milliards c'est absolument inimaginable
donc la puissance augmente tout le temps
les façon de raisonner de calcul et de
la programmation et donc je crois qu'on
va effectivement vers unia et il me
semble que si je devais choisir vous
définir la principale menace qui pèse
pour le monde
je ne dirais pas le réchauffement
climatique comme beaucoup de gens je
dirais l'intelligence artificielle et
d'ailleurs où il ya eu tout au colloque
ou
on imagine que c'est que justement les
machines pourront se révolter contre
l'homme puisque c'est le seul qui est
capable de les débrancher donc oui mais
la sécurité mais on aura peut-être
l'occasion de reparler parce que ce
livre est passionnant et puisque vous
dites sur notre avenir est tout à fait
plausible est aussi passionnant ça
s'appelle donc optimales 2121 le monde
dans son temps si proche si différents
et c'est de cette édition l'ombre rouge
merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]